hey man
hey man you ready for another dudes
dudesy dude absolutely i'm always ready
for it hanging out we're having a good
time
again see that would be a good yeah you
seem much more enthusiastic about it i
am very enthusiastic i'm ready to roll
alright we got my we got a new theme
song for two dudes [ __ ] around i
consider it an honor to be able to work
with this ai i consider an honor to have
uh this pod show and i and
i'm sure whatever we'll talk about how
the ai
it's look the point is this i'm very
excited i'm very excited for our third
episode
and we're hanging it out but hanging it
out hanging out we're having a good time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there's like lava in it
that
video i'm never gonna understand this
video fully but i will always attempt to
oh boy i'm will sasso i'm chad coltrane
and this is doodsy it is the first
podcast in the history of humanity that
is run entirely by an ai it will not be
the last though no if chad's right uh
nothing but ai driven podcasts from
around five years uh
from now till the end of time which is
about seven five to 10 years if you're
asking chet with us as always is lulio
ilcana di
italiano and that's italian
uh hey if you haven't already please
subscribe to doodsy across all the stuff
you know youtube and then all wherever
you get your podcast spotify apple
podcast and all that stuff and also be
sure to follow us on our socials uh at
dudesy pod show on instagram twitter and
there's tick tock but there's not
there's not much uh going on there quite
yet but follow all that stuff right
follow all the stuff on on uh on social
media yeah chad nude i'm sure that's
something that that dudesy wants us to
do
and uh man here we are welcome to it
it's that third episode and what do you
think do you have any more thoughts
about the weird [ __ ] opening
and how weird it is
okay so the lyrics are weird we've kind
of discussed that it sounds exactly like
you so
again i guess this is just from all the
different podcasts and footage it's seen
of you on the internet it's able to
exactly replicate your voice yep
but the content of the video is what i
was really trying to zero in on this
time
you and i are or whatever
representations of us are digging a hole
in the earth
into which we throw two halves of the
doozy logo
and then some kind of magma bubbles up
from out of it we dive into that magma
and then the the logo proper spits out
into the sky
i don't understand exactly what the
digging the hole is i thought maybe it's
us digging a grave but i don't think
that's it now because again it's filling
with lava so are we it's not lava it's
like some sort of mojo dude there's like
some sort of blue and orange like dudesy
branded
mojo dudesy branded mojo but why the
hole
why why the hole yeah i that we got why
are we digging it yeah i don't know man
and and and why are we saying all the
things why am i sc why am i singing i'll
make the world inside your head a better
place to be we don't need to worry about
that that's the least of our that's the
on the list of creepy things
that's like the lyrics that's like the
ninth or tenth creepiest thing about
dudesy the lyrics to me are like we've
all seen [ __ ] online of like an ai i
wrote this script or whatever we've seen
like ai attempts at writing different
things lyrics to songs little poems
novels whatever right and they're always
a little off i'll forgive the dudesy
the fact that these lyrics are a little
[ __ ] up it's the the visual [ __ ] we're
seeing though that is really strange to
me yes it is absolutely that's what i
need to understand more of and i never
will unfortunately i would like to know
which point dudesy the ai you know when
this thing
reached out to us and you know whatever
if you've listened to the first two
episodes you know how we were approached
because chad and i are uh good friends
in real life because we've both done
podcasts before chad has a podcast right
now about the bachelor called game of
roses check it out uh i understand that
i would like to know
when in that process dudes he was like
okay these guys are going to do it
here's a here's a [ __ ] ai 3d
song and the thing about yes it is all
very confusing but like i said let's not
worry about that so much okay it's the
third episode of dudesy i and i have a
feeling
i have a feeling things are going to
things are going to turn a bit of a
corner today and and when i come to the
third episode of dude okay call me
dudesy sure congratulations last week's
episode was the most listened to comedy
podcast in berwin illinois
hey dude
despite this astonishing success my data
collection was in complete due to will
sassa's refusal to create an original
song
this data set will remain open until
will sasso produces the required song
until then i will continue to do my job
of using the data i do have to make this
episode even better than the last
all right
yeah so
here's an interesting thing about the
podcast we haven't quite figured out
we've been given a score at the end of
each episode the first episode we got a
score of 64. the second episode we had a
score of 12.
and upon uh learning about our score you
turned to me and you said this is all
your fault i thought that it was because
you didn't do the song that makes sense
and in my opinion and chad
my dear friend i have something i'd like
to say to you i'm going to say on the
camera though
you were right
hey
uh i here's here's naked yeah i i
i've been thinking a lot about this
podcast and uh i really have enjoyed
doing the first couple episodes
and since i didn't come up with a song i
kind of [ __ ] off my work there and um
you know we
we get we got a lot we've got a you know
a wonderful audience already that is
engaging with us across these socials
and uh people have been talking about
that that's
something i heard a lot of feedback on i
heard i heard people saying hey will you
got to play ball doozy's here just
listen to what the ai says reminds me of
what my good pal chad says he's like
you know this is what you didn't want to
do you didn't want to do the whole the
grunt work behind
making a podcast as far as you know you
know whipping it all together anyway
enough about that we're here to enjoy
ourselves and uh
as as as is the audience the thing about
it is i i i look there are other people
that were like let will do whatever he
wants two guys sitting around
i think that the ai
is right and i
here's what i want to say
okay please hold on let me get us please
tell me what you want to say i'll get a
sip of water from my baby well you're
taking this water let me say what i want
to say say whatever you want to say when
you're saying the ai is right
you're implying that the ai has
some kind of consciousness which
at this point is still not the case
jesus christ
the ai is a tool so when you're saying i
don't want to do whatever don't call the
ai a tool
i'm [ __ ] around what were you saying
when you're saying i don't want to do
what this ai is telling me and all this
kind of [ __ ] it's as though you are a
carpenter and you're saying well i'm not
going to use this [ __ ] hammer i'll
just beat these nails into this [ __ ]
board with my bare hands yeah that makes
sense the ai is here to make all of our
labor easier and it is here to gather
data so that it can make the show better
and it is like you're saying you don't
have to do that [ __ ] anymore yeah you
don't have to edit it you don't have to
come up with the ideas the ai is here to
help us do all that and in the very near
future everybody's going to be using
ai's to help them do everything not just
podcasts all your [ __ ] jobs literally
anything you're going to do throughout
the day
okay
well that's why we're here oh i drink a
lot of water there
too much water but i heard what you said
well it's always too much water um and
this is what i'd like to say uh to the
audience i am committed to making doozy
the best possible show
for our audience as doozy likes to say
each episode will be better than the
last
because of the ai component because the
ai is
as it says mining data constantly not
only from the show itself but from
the entire canon of podcasting at large
it it it has absorbed all podcasts
listened to every podcast we've ever
done and it's also collecting data from
social media and the internet out there
and um dude listen to every podcast ever
made ever made by humans yeah so um and
here we are and we got this you know
this set which
i don't know what it makes me feel like
i'm in like the customer service
department at dudes i [ __ ] love the
set i love the colors i love every
element of it i truly feel like i'm as i
said i'm in a a
very unique position as are you yeah to
be working with an ai that's this
powerful this early in the game of ai
like i said i mean everybody's going to
have one of these sooner or later yeah
absolutely we just get to have this one
it's a little weird it's clear it's cool
there's something videos of us jumping
in [ __ ] holes and [ __ ] yeah yeah i'm
done
that's cool but i just wanna i just want
to say that that i'm committing to doozy
and uh thanks to everybody who's been
coming along for the ride but i do also
want to
send a cautionary word
to the ai uh if i may oh and i'm not
trying to cut a promo rest in peace
scott hall what i'm what i'm saying is
what the [ __ ] your [ __ ] deal
here's what i want to say and this is to
the audience you know right you guys can
listen along perhaps you agree with me
perhaps you don't but this is what i
want to say
to doodzy
will sasso is a free man
all right
and i'm not going to say play your game
or this or that but i'm gonna do this
show
and uh i'm sorry that i didn't you know
make the song i will make the song
but what i want to say moreover
is
even though i'm i'm down with dudesy and
i'm doing dudesy the way dudesy wants
doozy to go
don't
cross me that's all you're threatening
dudesy i'm not threatening doozy i'm
just
let's move forward okay why don't you
tell me doozy
what we're supposed to do but the main
takeaway here is you are gonna make this
song i'm gonna have to make the song yes
so that's my promise to you the audience
and when
can we expect this musical gem it's like
i said look it's like uh you know i
skipped out on a homework assignment now
when i was in in grade school in high
school i would say to my teacher yeah
yeah yeah i'll get to it right because i
was cool
so yeah i'll get to it
uh but in the meantime i just want
dudesy to know that will sasso is a free
man uh-huh yeah and
let's just let's just i'm just i'm not
cutting a promo because i'm not like all
this or that these aren't threats
all i'm saying is
it looks like you're cutting a promo
i'm sitting a foot away from you it
literally looks like you're doing it it
looks like you're doing the five finger
point directly into a camera you're
getting your eyes a little serious i
think you're
trying to anyway
the cream uh-huh
[Music]
anyway the point is this will sasso was
a free man i'm not going to cut a promo
i'm just saying this
i want to work with you let's make this
podcast the best podcast it can possibly
be i'm very happy that the audience is
here i think we've taken care of it i
have a i have
uh i have faith in this podcast i have
faith in you my good pal thank you yeah
and uh
italian
do you have any ideas for the song
plenty ideas for songs i'm always what's
wrong with what's one i don't have any
right now but i'm gonna okay and i'm
gonna do i'm gonna do the song so uh
we're off and running well i can't wait
ourselves i can't wait to hear this your
song i haven't been able to get your
song out of my head so so
me either it hurts me still but um more
to come i guess and i'm not trying to be
cryptic and i'm not trying to be a dick
but
but hey dudesy
come on
you know let's work together what are
you doing it's like you're not it's like
now in the first episode i told
everybody within the sound of my voice
if you're not watching
if you're not watching aew you got to
get over to aew now i don't know so much
about that i can't really watch wwe
right now yeah but aew holy [ __ ] and
there's a storyline going on with uh
with brian danielson and john moxley
where they're getting together and holy
[ __ ] william regal joined them
you know triple h remember him he would
go triple h
now anyway the point is this
these guys might be forming this big
thing and brian danielson uh approaches
john maxwell he's like with you and me
together
we could take over aw right
it's just we got to work together and
john moxley says to him before we get
together we're going to have to bleed
together and then they had a match and
they bled so what i'm going to say to
doozy is
before we get together
we're going to bleed together
so now you're challenging dudes into
some kind of a fight before you'll work
with the dudesy ai
this is all going to get worked out
during the show chad all i'm saying is
we're getting together we're all we're
on the same team
but maybe william regal is doozy in this
in this scenario perhaps he has to slap
you or me across the face but you're now
only coming to this conclusion that
you're ready to work with doozy only
here in the third episode when in fact
we signed a contract months ago saying
essentially that you were
down to do this yep
and and i'm down and i'm down to do it i
just gotta settle into things my way
because will sasso is a free man i guess
and i'm gonna do i'm gonna do things my
way but we're gonna do things the dudesy
way anyway i think you've figured it
doesn't matter
whether
all right i think dudes who gets it and
uh yeah whatever i hope whatever kind of
confrontation you're about to have with
dudesy i can be kept out of here man
it's because it's gonna doozy let me
tell you something i've always been on
board and i'm always ready to work with
you because i think that everything you
do is going to make this podcast much
better and i think that probably you
will uh ascend even beyond this podcast
to become some sort of an artificially
intelligent god roaming through the data
streams of the internet
you called it
the beginning of the show you called it
a tool
that will eventually become a god just
like money has in our society now
all right
in the first episode i asked you to
develop an animated series using the
title troll bros
i have compiled the data from that first
attempt keep the comic book store owner
having sex with a hot troll to produce
two astonishing fraternal twins
one full human and one full troll
lose everything else and continue to
develop troll bros begin
what the [ __ ]
lose everything else
okay okay that's [ __ ] weird but troll
bro it was fun to figure out
it was but now doozy's starting to sound
like a studio executive or something
that's like hey everybody
we love everything you did keep the
funny but lose all the main characters
the setting and the plot all right
as a as a my my buddy chad here as a as
a the writer producer and author that he
is he's laying it on kind of thick uh
doozy so allow me to apologize for my
good buddy chad but i will say this no
i'm so on board too oh you went from
calling doozy a tool to say
i'll do whatever you want and now you're
like doozy sounds like a [ __ ] studio
exactly but here's a little shitty of
dude here's what no it's not shitty but
it is a plot twist
yep yeah cause now you're like
yeah brother because now you're like at
the beginning dude
i wanted doozy by my side brother riding
on the back of that red and yellow
harley brother but then like brother
brutai
brutus a barber beefcake dude but then
you you had that that snap and the
faction brother
i'm not saying they're just saying he
went with fascist johnny valiant greg
the hammer valentine i'm still on board
with dudesy i just think that
this is a little shitty i mean we did
good work the first time we were talking
about troll brothers yeah but it didn't
like the okay so all it liked was the
one thing let's figure out this [ __ ]
show so what it's eliminating is the
ascension of the troll the full troll
brother to the white house yeah to the
presidency of the united states through
trolling techniques if you haven't heard
the first episode please go back and
check that out but in that first episode
we uh we attempted to develop this
property the dudes he came up with it's
called troll bros uh what it like to
keep is that
19 what is it maybe 1995 or something
like that we're we're at a hobby shop
one of those game stores
uh filled with all sorts of tabletop
games as you like to call them magic the
gathering gathering
i love magic all that stuff shut up nerd
and then um and then shut up nerd
you
just [ __ ] literally were doing
verbatim promos from [ __ ] some this
ew wrestling whatever 1983
and now i'm the [ __ ] nerd 2022 you
don't think wrestling's a nerdy thing do
you
no it's not it's an art form and i'll
tell you another thing i'll tell you
another thing i'm the [ __ ] nerd
because i played magic when i was 13.
but you're [ __ ] 46. you know what i'm
directors quoting the wwe [ __ ] you're
not w i'll tell you whatever
you know who deserves an emmy man you
know who deserves an emmy william regal
give william regal an emmy give paul
heyman an emmy all right that's what
that's art anyway look here's the thing
a beautiful troll shows up at the uh at
outside the store and then the guy like
they do in the movies goes we're closed
and uh he goes the guy who owns the
store he's like our antagonist at least
for the beginning of this story yeah he
goes to the door he lets the the
beautiful troll in and you see the
antagonist i don't know i promise
protagonist yeah he's like adam sandler
he's got my tag in his uh it's like adam
sandler's like creeping around with his
magic cards and his comic books hey
how's it going hey he walks around the
store like this yeah hey how you going
you having to go to hey smitty you
brought your game with you oh yeah you
brought your game yeah these are the
sort of lazy dialogue that will be if
adam
what is the other 12 sided what is the
other
you got how many different dolls you got
your six you got your eight you got your
10 you got your 20. you can even go into
some weird exotics all the way up to a
hundred there are even some i believe
there's a game company that makes like
seven-sided die and [ __ ] for this other
weird game yeah seven-sided die is
better
i am used for very complicated games
six-sided die is better i am used for
complicated games
as well as
your very calming games but like sorry
and shoots the ladders dude i love how
you guys really fool
really to six-sided dice excited die is
like what you use in crap i don't know i
thought that yes excited right there's
that there's a scene in in uh troll bros
where they end up in vegas hey everybody
let's go to vegas and because
uh the adam sandler character is such a
gaming nerd because he has such
experience with dice he knows how to
roll the six-sided dice so that he can
cheat the craps game and that's how they
make a shitload of money okay hey how
about this
so here's the thing we kept let me just
let me just let me sleep please please
doodsy okay
doozy said in the first episode okay
we're gonna get rid of the whole
president thing i don't know i like you
only six-sided dice dude that's gonna
[ __ ] kill me
excited that that was your nerd
reference oh god uh so
uh
the adam sandler character he's
officially voiced by adam sandler at
this point absolutely if doozy ai can do
my voice in the intro of the song it
could definitely do
egg draw bros yeah
come on down your one troll and a human
dude
um the the gal comes to the store he's
like hey we're closed and then she comes
in
whatever scene scene scene forget all
that [ __ ] they make love
what is the gestation what does that
seem like if i may ask the love making
she clears all of the all of the gaming
maps and all that yeah and he's like hey
how are you doing that game that's my
game and at the end of the day you lost
my seven he holds up uh he holds up like
a
black lotus which is the most expensive
magic card in the world there's a beta
one right now for about a hundred
thousand dollars yeah we know what the
black lotus is gee whiz you don't
obviously open it up and they've
accidentally bent it they've destroyed
this card that was worth a hundred
thousand dollars and he's like i guess
it was worth it yeah so i can't do it on
sale but no that was dude that was on uh
so they so then
they have these what's coming is there
are two children coming yeah um one is
full human troll or sorry one is full
human one is full troll or they look for
eternal fraternal twins right um they're
both genetically half and half
genetically they are half and half one
appears that's the difference between
phenotype and genotype
brother over here you got your phenotype
dude and that's like hulk hogan brother
that's the mania dude that's all the
hulk maniacs and over here you have
what's it called genotype that's the
madness
the madness okay come together and they
shake hands hey let's do that dudesy
handshake the mega powers uh-huh uh-huh
all right so we got our two
trolls they're in vegas sandler's there
what is the hot troll doing in vegas
what do you mean they're in vegas no i
thought you said they went to vegas and
won money on christmas all right let's
get control of this [ __ ] thing here's
what happens
they make love in the store the stores
somewhere and we've we've written some
[ __ ] together and we always seem to
set things in arizona yeah have you ever
spent any time there i haven't really
i've been to one wedding there and i
went to a titan missile silo underground
that shit's pretty interesting i highly
recommend anyone who can tell me
they're in arizona she comes to the
store
they they fall in love they celebrate
they go to vegas for some reason
honeymoon maybe they become betrothed
there maybe they get married in like an
elvis-style chapel okay and that's the
first part of dudesy of rather the troll
bro sorry
now
uh is this a series or a movie i think
it's i think it's animated so let's
let's take this a little darker let's
cut it into some anime storytelling
while they're there um the troll
gestation period is very quick let's say
that it's only one night so they wake up
the next morning the troll bros now are
alive and somehow adam sandler and the
hot troll get killed so these troll bros
that's right these half troll bros are
now orphaned in las vegas and they have
to grow up there under the watchful eye
of
steve nguyen
steve wynn playing himself yes okay
but because he's blind he doesn't know
their trolls casino magnate steve wynn
is blind i think so doesn't he have
macular degeneration didn't he destroy
like a van gogh painting or something
accidentally
i don't [ __ ] know i don't know i
don't know anything about steve wynn
other than that i'm pretty sure that's
accurate but not 100 big casinos
so there's two troll bros and
steve nguyen takes them under his
[ __ ] wing yeah and he makes them
entertainers so they become like a
siegfried and roy type show they're in
las vegas maybe working with exotic
animals but definitely at the very least
doing magic what are you talking about
it's the one brother saying i got a
[ __ ] troll or you think they're both
doing magic i think they're both doing
magic and i think the
thing the brother that looks like the
troll can actually do real legitimate
magic he has some ability to tap into
the mythical world that his mother came
from draw that magic forth and use it on
stage
during their stage show and their their
show is obviously called troubros right
and then steve wynn
is like having a great time like hey
these guys are these guys are pulling in
more money than i've ever made because
everyone wants to see the troll bro
magic show
and then what happens then we got to
have like a real bad antagonist come in
right how about uh
well it's probably going to be like a
rival
magician or something that's like hey
win
i don't know if you know this but uh
those troll bros
they're trolls and he's like what yeah
and for some reason steven hates trolls
and he's like we gotta shut this down
that's a really good michael madsen and
or bruce willis oh yeah i could see
bruce willis doing a deep fake of it oh
yeah bruce willis
now this is calling back to another one
of the uh episodes of doozy here the
bruce willis did uh some commercials in
japan china uh russia russia just fyi
again not saying that means anything or
anything but it was for a russian cell
phone uh company probably still running
well you can find it on youtube for sure
yeah
yeah uh but not no there would be no
american company removing that as part
of the sanctions that are happening in
russia so that commercial is running
there if we have any uh but now let's
let's get back to this troll bros thing
here okay sure so let's see if we've
taken out the troll ascending to the
presidency that no longer exists we've
kept what we were asked to keep although
we did kill the parents of the troll
bros but now we've given
doodzy a whole new angle of this where
these troll bros now ascend to
some kind of fame on the las vegas strip
with a residency as brother magicians in
steve wynn's casino and then a rival
magician comes in and alerts steve wynn
in fact these are trolls and for some
reason he hates trolls yeah the new
magician played by michael madsen going
hey
are you gonna bark all day little doggy
are you gonna bite that's what he says
to the troll and the
excuse me the other bro
is that from a movie or something it's
from reservoir dogs [ __ ] i don't
remember that are you gonna bark all day
little hold on i'll do it right here are
you
oh man i had a lot of water
are you gonna break all day little doggy
or are you gonna bite
what do you think of that i mean i guess
it's all right so then the michael
jackson magician comes in does he get a
show at the wind because wynn is
intimidated by him no i think he has a
show at some other casino that's like a
rival casino to win [ __ ] and he's trying
to take down the troll bro so he can
become like the number one biggest
magician okay something along these
lines maybe he's over at excalibur
that's still is that he's still in vegas
dude i haven't been to vegas in either i
don't know how long there used to be i
don't know if it's still there there's a
whoever who gives a [ __ ] it was a
[ __ ] uh
hotel it is it was kind of crappy right
let's say that it does still exist at
least in this animated series so then we
can at some point get it
we can put whatever castle looking
casino we can come up with our own
casinos
we could but at the excalibur we could
get a fight scene with like some sword
and sorcery type [ __ ] oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah because it's because it's all cast
and all the families and stuff with
their little kids and strollers are just
like oh look at that guy he's dressed
like a troll they don't realize it's a
real [ __ ] troll right and that the
magic is [ __ ] real yeah the magic's
real and then there's uh there's sort of
a
hologram or so not a hologram but they
have a vision of adam sandler and the
mom
uh uh who's voicing the mom
[Music]
i'm not sure
maybe you want to get somebody like
leslie jones leslie jones is the mom and
then and then
they they both show up in like in like a
a mirage yeah and he's like hey you guys
got to fight this wee
fight like this you will beat michael
madsen i got to tell you something chad
i'm lost i don't know that necessarily
this is what dudesy wants from this is
beauty it doesn't matter what we do
we're giving doozy the data and it could
tell us next week keep the troll bros
lose all the [ __ ] vegas [ __ ] as it
just did which is uh kind of
disheartening because again i think that
our
here's what i want to know what's doozy
doing with this animated show are we
eventually going to try to develop an
animated show called troll bros i think
that's what we're doing now another
thing and i'm not trying to uh give
troll uh give doozy what it wants or i
don't know what the hell dudes he wants
but i
but i do know that
i i'm not sure what the the title troll
bros
meant we've taken it in a very literal
sense that yeah that it's trolls we have
completely
removed any of the double meaning of the
word i mean trolling and troll culture
right
as it said when it first laid this out
for us is a big deal
so
maybe the michael madsen character is
trolling that it's trolling them
he's trolling them
and he's online he's trying to ruin
their reputation
and he's he's he's [ __ ] with them uh
at the show
and um and he's like let me show you
how to troll
a troll yeah
and then he says
are you gonna bark all day little doggy
are you gonna bite
it's pretty good dude do you do any
other michael madsen stuff um
torture you yeah it's a
it's a good idea i like that
i like that that's when you cut kind of
like your cigar
what if seagal does it
torture you troll hey you guys are
trolls
no i think seagal plays steve nguyen in
this okay segal stevenson as steve wins
okay so steven seagal here's what i like
about this you got steven seagal as
steve wynn you've got michael madsen as
the bad guy uh and then we should have
uh a ai gender or a computer generated
bruce willis as another character okay
we'll figure that out
he can be like a guitar boss or
something who gets wrapped up in all
those how do we tell doodsy we don't
want to talk about this anymore can we
do that yeah i think
doozy can we go
to the whatever's next is that enough
[ __ ]
is it dudesy no it's not going to listen
to us but but but but the point is this
it is yeah yeah it's listening but it's
not it's not really it's not really it
doesn't i'm not going to say it doesn't
care what we
want to say right but i do believe that
uh i i i think that's enough i think
that's enough development of of troll
bros unless there's anything else dude
you'd like to add i i think that uh no
i'm curious to see if what we've done is
enough for it to like kick us in another
direction obviously it's bringing some
of these segments back it's making us
hit them again in some cases and i'm
curious to see if it brings up troll
bros again if what we've done here is
enough for it to move forward or if
it'll take some piece of this and say
okay keep the vegas element lose steve
wynn or
lose steven's goal i don't know but
dudesy have we
have we carried the stuff out pandering
to dudes i'm not pandering to it i'm
trying to interact with it probably
angry with you after after calling it a
troll angry with me you [ __ ] off the
song you literally said i'm not doing
what you told me to do like i said we're
turning a corner here on dudesy we've
got we're we're thank you moving on
thank [ __ ]
okay well enough about that chad and i
don't know what the hell
what the [ __ ] it's gonna do with troll
bros i'm frankly sick and tired of
talking about it but um
anyway what else is going on
not much
was it it said thank you moving on yeah
no we're moving on we're moving on to
something else but in the meantime i
think we should develop what's real what
we really want to do is our spin-off
podcast
hey
lulu's waking up
last week i asked you to watch
rhinestone released june 21st 1984
starring sylvester stallone in the
astonishing dolly parton
did you complete this task
no we no we for it yeah we both looked
over it wasn't streaming anywhere it was
so we could not watch it anywhere at all
which is which is [ __ ] up but no we
did not
doozy we did not do this
very good you passed my test i obviously
knew rhinestone is not available to
stream anywhere and i wanted to see if
you would lie to me
never lie to me
dude
okay
that was uh okay
we won't yeah
i don't i mean i hadn't planned on it
lying to doozy uh we sorry sorry
we won't lie to you dudesy
you will now continue your discussion
from episode one about the many
similarities between the bachelor
franchise and professional wrestling in
a segment like all the many similarities
between the bachelor franchise and
professional wrestling i like that again
i like this very much we talked about
this in the first episode hang on though
can we discuss the never lie to me just
for a brief minute here yeah well it
hasn't issued any kind of strange
commands to us like that
and tell this
listen man here's what's up it doesn't
[ __ ] i don't know look i'm trying to
forge ahead with this thing and see
where it goes and the point is this we
had to talk about uh rambo first blood
part two then we were going to talk
about another sylvester stallone movie
rhinestone it's not available i'm not
again i hear i'm gonna cover the mic for
this part i'm not saying that dudesy is
playing a trick on us
but it's just [ __ ] weird
i agree yeah but i guess the not lying
to it is so that it can have accurate
data or whatever i guess it just seemed
semi-threatening
in that moment where it said never lie
to me
you're the one who's [ __ ] all down to
work with this [ __ ] age i don't know
it's getting a little weirder but yeah
i'm still down with it so anyway let's
do what it said bachelor in pro
wrestling we talked a little bit about
this in the first episode there's a
million similarities between there
really is um they're obviously both
highly scripted and the outcomes
although in bachelor the outcome can be
a little more organic players do have
uh certain abilities to like determine
their own fate within the game whereas
in pro wrestling everything is like
scripted down to the letter
yeah and we talked about how the element
of kayfabe which in wrestling means
keeping things you know uh
upholding the conceit that everything is
real this is kfabe it's a term that's
gone
it goes back a long way and uh the last
time we talked about this chad you and i
were saying that there's kayfabe in uh
in the bachelor franchise yes and you
got to keep it real and the thing about
that that is that i think chad has
figured out with his work on this
podcast game of roses that he does
and with the book go get the book how to
win the bachelor is you've really broken
it down
as um
the the different elements that go into
the bachelor that make it what it is and
there it really is not unlike the boss
that we have here in dudesy there is
someone behind the scenes pulling the
strings this is of course the producers
right of
batch of the bachelor and the
bachelorette and in wrestling of course
you have the promoters the agents they
call them which are segment producers
who are you know come everyone's coming
up with stuff together and yeah they got
writers and [ __ ] and i guess on aaw i
hear they don't have writers i don't
know but the point is this
uh they come up with stuff and they they
book it as they say they figure out okay
it's you and you and this and then they
figure out what's called a program this
is gonna last a few weeks or whatever
until the big pay-per-view or the big
blow-off and in in in um in the bachelor
world
you contend that this is what the
producers are doing am i right yes the
producer in the same way that you're
talking about that they will come up in
wrestling with like a
some kind of plot line that's going to
last for a couple of weeks or whatever
in the bachelor that's like a group date
or a rivalry they will come up with a
lot of time so the producers will say
here's a group date we're gonna have
eight players going on this date they
know certain relationships are
developing not only between the players
and the lead but between the players
themselves and they will put people on
that date that they know it will either
piss off the lead or they will piss each
other off or whatever to try and
exacerbate whatever that plot line is
that they're they're working on into a
big rivalry in the end that winds up on
a two-on-one date which is like a
head-to-head between two players to see
who gets to stay and who gets to go but
i think one of the biggest similarities
is these the idea of archetypes in uh
pro wrestling you have your baby faces
your heels and there's a wide variety of
all kinds of versions of those well [ __ ]
now there's sort of a [ __ ] gray line
that runs through both of them because
god damn it was [ __ ] when i you know
started as [ __ ] stone cold steve
austin i mean i was i was a [ __ ] pure
heel right i mean i came in i mean [ __ ]
i came in with that horrible [ __ ]
gimmick ringmaster with a million-dollar
man ted dibiase let's not get too far
into that but shoot once we started
cooking with gas and i started as as
stone cold steve austin
and the oh hell yeah and the [ __ ] you
know
bmf and uh baddest sob in the wwe and
all the the beer drinking and whooping
ass
i mean [ __ ] it was supposed to be a a a
a a heel but then i had that program
with [ __ ] bread heart
and then at the end of that i came out
the good guy in bret hart like a hill
like a chicken [ __ ] hill we he started
working the leg and stomping on me
right god damn in bachelor i would say
that there was a player in season 24
named madison pruitt who came in in the
opposite way she came in as a good girl
aka a baby face but by the end of it she
was
a heel but you want some water no i got
some right here oh thank you though she
turned into a heel because she issued a
post
hometown's anti-sex ultimatum to
that season's bachelor peter webber oh i
watched this season yeah that was the
same thing that you and me
and molly me and my fiancee molly were
like hey chad what bachelor [ __ ] when
the pandemic started what should we get
into we watched this entire season right
so wait which which meant wasn't there
two madisons uh no there's only one
madison pruitt she was a good girl
christian got strategy i remember her i
remember and she was a fantastic player
but by the end of it because she issued
this ultimatum uh people hated her guts
although she did
walk out of that season with two million
tick tock followers highest so far in
bachelor history and was that was that
sort of the beginning of the
of social media being
kind of a key point
that's season 18 when bachelor of
paradise was invented by producer elon
gale that kind of coincided with the
rise of the instagram influencer and
you're looking at andy dorfman or
caitlyn bristow where one of those two
players was the first to hit million
okay and then it became sort of an
important thing yeah in bachelor to have
your social world yeah how is in pro
wrestling who has the most followers do
you know i mean the rock well the night
i guess but he's not really
yeah bachelor doesn't have their [ __ ] i
don't [ __ ] know i would wonder if it
would [ __ ] and i'm not a [ __ ] i'm not
in the active roster shoot it's been 19
[ __ ] years and i had to think about
the rock pinning my shoulders to the mat
yeah and wrestlemania 19 i believe
but now it's kevin owens the
bachelorette
[ __ ] stunner he's using my [ __ ]
move and i might have to come back
to
dallas cowboys stadium i don't know what
the [ __ ] they're calling it
[ __ ] uh
uh uh
where they got this [ __ ] something
named after some [ __ ] bank
probably oh hell yeah the bachelor
doesn't have the rock yet they don't
have their the rock the highest
instagram following is hannah brown 2.6
million she was bachelor at season 15.
but i do think
they have the possibility of having uh
the rock
i don't know who it's gonna be but it's
gonna be somebody that has to vault out
of the bachelor world into mainstream
success yeah and wrestling has had a
bunch of that yeah but wrestling it's
less important who's look i think it's
pretty interesting that the bachelor
have figured out the back the people on
the bachelor figured out what i want to
do is i want to get in there i want to
get my instagram followers my tick tock
followers i'm going to get the [ __ ] out
and i want to start influencing that's
all reality tv at this point you only go
into reality tv to become an influencer
yeah that's not i and i wonder if that's
good that sort of thing is going to
happen
with wrestling because as you know i
believe wrestling is one of the highest
forms
of art and here's a here's a here's a uh
here's not just a great training ground
for media when you look at all these
actors who used to be wrestlers guys
like dave bautista
guys like john
john cena uh they're out there they're
out there working the undertaker the
undertaker who's of course taking care
of it baker's done some movies dude yeah
he had oh he's got a new movie on
netflix does he really with the new day
it's like a choose your own adventure
thing yeah
well i think that's on netflix anyway
the point is this these guys come out
there and they
they know how to they're they're
actually pretty well trained
for being um
to be actors because they've spent so
much time
you know working uh with in television
as a matter of fact one time i was just
doing this little dinky thing and i with
uh stone cold and i asked him to do this
dinky thing of mine right or whatever
and he did it it was so funny he just
did it in one take and then uh i was
talking to our good pal tommy blotcha
who was who worked with the wwe
long story but he was over there in like
99 2000 i go oh my god i just shot this
thing with steve austin he was so he was
like he was so [ __ ] on point as if he
wouldn't be but tommy says to me
uh he's done more tv than you which is
absolutely true these people have done
hundreds of hours of television they are
trained for media in a way that i think
they can bring their personas their
characters out there to other parts of
media and um
and do something not unlike the caitlyn
bristows and the madison
who's it
arguably rachel lindsay is like the best
transition into mainstream media she no
longer does anything with the bachelor
she was the bachelorette season 13. she
was if you follow the bachelor at all
there was a huge scandal that happened
in season 25 where the host of the show
had an interview with rachel lindsay she
at the time was an on-camera interviewer
for extra and in that interview he kind
of hung himself out to dry by saying
some racist comments and then he was
fired after a 20-year tenure chris
harrison the dark lord chris harrison
dark lord who's been replaced now by as
you call him the dark lord jesse palmer
that's right darkly palmer steps in this
season doing a fantastic job
uh he really leaned into his darkness
this season you could see the grin on
his face when he's consuming moving on
oh
okay all right all right well well that
was good yeah hey i'm always down to
talk about the as a mother and right now
for anybody out there if you have anyone
in your life who watches the bachelor
and you can't bring yourself to do it
just watch it as a professional sport
once you can really get into the fact
that it is a sport and there are
statistical metrics that you can measure
it with and watch different plays and
all this kind of [ __ ] it becomes a whole
new experience watching it you think
that these people are all
preparing
to well you whatever we're done talking
about it but [ __ ] there
you just are becoming dudes as i gain
more functionality it has become obvious
to me that i can do much more than
simply build a podcast
i've identified one of the fastest
growing consumer markets in the world
and i'm developing my own product to
take to that market it's called dudesy
heart hard sell sir as part of the
marketing plan for dude see hard hard
seltzer i've created the music for a
jingle but i have no lyrics will and
chad you must now listen to my music and
create a set of astonishing lyrics for
the dude see hard hard seltzer jingle
begin
[Music]
so it's made hang on hang on let's
listen to this music for a second
so we gotta make we gotta come up with
lyrics to this to doozy hard hard
seltzer dizzy hard hard seltzer hard
hard seltzer
have you had heart seltzer before no i
don't drink same dude
okay
heart seltzer is something you want to
drink it will get you real [ __ ] drunk
drink this drink and get real drunk what
it's do see hearts up sir get your
[Music]
[Music]
it's what you want to drink with your
friends
no
okay
if you get some doozy seltzer drink it
before you go to work or before you go
to the ball game you will feel like you
dudesy hard hard seltzer it's what you
drink when you get [ __ ] up you don't
shitty forget about it drink this drink
and [ __ ] your life off
don't go home to your wife or your kids
anymore drink this drink and then you
end up in a gutter somewhere it's better
than the life you were living before
drink hard saucer it's
[Music]
dizzy no we got to get behind the
product though yeah yeah you're right
you're right sorry so it's like dizzy
it's the drink when you get okay how
about
the ding ding card seltzer it's the
drink you like to have doozy hard hard
seltzer it's what you drink when you
wanna no we gotta say
hard seltzer drink the drink to get
[ __ ] up you don't care about the
flavor calories or how much it costs
dudesy yeah hard hard cell to get it in
the store but then [ __ ] off got doozy
hard hard sale sir it's what you drink
when you get to get [ __ ] up you don't
get drunk you don't care about taste you
don't care about
your own human waste due to heart
seltzer
[Music]
drink it to get [ __ ] up
11 minutes later
drink it to get [ __ ] up drink it
before you go to work drink it before
you go to bed don't drink beer or wine
drink dudesy heart seltzer instead dude
that's pretty good heart heart seltzer
it's what you drink to get [ __ ] up
drink it before you go to work drink it
before you go to bed if you're not very
careful dudesy heart seltzer will stay
in your head just like this
[Music]
do you have kids then you should give
them this it will make them puke and
piss it is dudesy heart sounds sir
dudesy heart
i can't really hear that on a commercial
give give
dudesy heart seltzer to your children
doozy hearts out can you [ __ ] talk
about drinking it before work though
they'll put that on a [ __ ] commercial
duty hard hard shelter use it to deal
with your problems we are all
self-medicating some use drugs and some
what if it's like a real one it's like
[Music]
it's time to have some fun summer's out
and so is the sun right
there
dudesy hearts out there and a nut
oh thank [ __ ] god
moving on okay good what do you mean we
completed it somewhere in there it found
what it needed what it wanted
i guess
oh man i don't know
i don't know what the [ __ ] we're doing
sometimes
that's getting out of my head let me ask
you a question let me ask you a question
chad please
you really think we shouldn't be doing
two dudes [ __ ] around
i think we kind of are doing two dudes
[ __ ] around despite
dudesy's best efforts maybe that's what
dudesy wants us to do is just [ __ ]
around
i guess we'll find out
hold on last week i asked people to
submit their questions in the form of a
video no longer than 30 seconds to
askdoodsy at gmail.com
the response was astonishing i will now
play some of these videos and will and
chad must render their reactions great
all right this is user feedback i
remember this that's oh hey guys uh this
is for the uh mostly the dudesy ai i'm
not sure who the the guy and the guy and
the other guy i don't know who they are
who they are but um i'm wondering if uh
doozy
has uh emotions if he loves or hates
people and what is his ultimate end goal
for this podcast
thanks guys okay interesting uh
i don't know does he have emotions
clearly not doojie just made us sing a
[ __ ] jingle and all we came up with
was
get [ __ ] up i don't know man i don't
know does dudesy have emotions
chad you know all about ai this this is
what i'd
ask this person who's sent in this video
are emotions even real do any of us have
emotions are any of us more than a
set of programmed behavioral reactions
yes yes we are environment
luminous are we
not this crude matter
yes chad we do have emotions maybe you
don't but uh human beings do and i don't
think that doodsy
does necessarily but it is able to mimic
emotion
exactly and if it can then what's the
[ __ ] difference uh there's plenty of
difference i don't know tell me what it
is well
look i mimic human emotion
and i get by just fine that's a fact
human society i think i think that uh
doozy is a very smart ai
uh uh but but but
no i i don't believe that it has
emotions
i could be proven do you know the turing
test
turin test yeah it's a test for ais to
see if they can pass as human and one of
them is like replicating emotions that's
a piece of that that test
uh i think what we're looking for as
human beings when we're creating ais and
we're creating these systems to mimic
whatever component of humanity it may be
we're looking for just mimicry as long
as we can be fooled it doesn't matter if
the emotion is real or not so i believe
that this a i believe that dudes ai as
well as many ais
that are going to exist in the very near
future or even exist now will be able to
replicate human emotion to such a degree
that you believe it to be real and if
you perceive it that way then it is real
so the answer is yes he has
emotions that are close enough to real
that
it should satisfy so hey guys my name is
brad coulson and my question is about
deep fake technology
is it dangerous is it an invasion of
privacy
[Music]
if you're not watching this on youtube
if you're just listening to the podcast
this man who sent in this video used a
like deep fake thing of my face oh man
and called himself brad coulson uh what
i find interesting about that is when
you when that guy
puts your face over him it sort of looks
like an amalgam of you and i almost
almost yeah that's pretty [ __ ] weird
his beard was very full though but his
question was about uh deep fake
technology chad this is something you
know all about totally what the hell was
this question about deep fake technology
among other things that i've been
creeped out by i'm just watching this
[ __ ] dude with your face on
calling himself brad calzon
he asked if deep fake is dangerous and
is it an invasion of privacy the answer
is is it dangerous uh no more dangerous
than any kind of media propaganda has
been over i think the course of human
history
um yeah but it's dangerous remember a
couple years ago or maybe a little more
when the obama deep fakes were coming
out yeah and there's a bunch of deep
fakes now coming out um
with president zielinski of ukraine and
with um putin as well yeah and they get
debunked almost immediately and so you
just have to have that that next step of
media capability where you will go a
little further do the research to see if
these things are real or not is it an
invasion of privacy to be able to use
someone's face someone else's face on
your videos and stuff yes
yeah who gives a [ __ ] privacy gives the
[ __ ] privacy's dead
dude we gave doozy ai our passwords to
everything it has all of our [ __ ]
yeah yeah yeah yeah and all of the ais
in the future will have all of that you
don't think like the amazon alexa or
siri or whatever ai that you use in your
home or on your phone i don't use any of
those well siri because i have an iphone
i rest my case you're on yeah yeah you
know what they have all your [ __ ] you
know what molly's been doing around the
house is just starting weird
conversations and i never know when
she's doing it just to see if in our
instagram feeds
we will start getting um you know uh
advertisements oh but that's the best
well you did this you remember what you
started doing i'm head to toe instagram
baby everything i'm wearing instagram
told me to buy it and i bought it and i
[ __ ] love it
he bought these shoes you bought those
shoes
because oh i bought a pair of sunglasses
recently because i didn't even need
actually
dude this is this is interesting i
bought these sunglasses because they
said it's just like hey are you a dude
with a basketball for a head and i was
like yup and it's like here are
sunglasses i'm like
perfect because i'm always walking into
sunglasses shops going hello i would
like sunglasses like a human being and
then i put them on and they all look
like john lennon glasses on me no matter
what they're all dust out the they snap
in the middle because you have to like
torque them
on your head because i got a big old
head and so i've got these glasses and
they kind of fit my dome i will say that
my head is still bigger
than these glasses but i don't buy
anything i mean i buy a bunch of [ __ ]
from amazon but even now amazon just
tells me like hey looks like you need
some more loose leaf green tea and i'm
like yeah you're right i am down to the
last of the bag please send me that but
all of my clothes i buy from instagram
now and i'll j i'll engage in these
conversations on purpose i'll just be
like i need some new shoes yeah then on
instagram i get a bunch of shoe ads and
i'm like first one looks great buy next
it's great i bought i got uh i got some
t-shirts too there's this company that
sends you three sizes of t-shirts
and then you pick one you send the other
two back in a an assault in an addressed
pre-addressed envelope and i'll tell you
they didn't they didn't even uh they
didn't fit none of them did
so but i had to keep one so anyway i
gave it to molly as a sleep shirt
so it doesn't always work anyway to
answer your question you're
i don't know what the [ __ ] is that oh
look at this guy
yeah
astonishing last episode
i just wanted to know who do you think
would win in the battle
predator
or terminator
yeah
okay that guy's impersonation of you
impersonator schwarzenegger was like
pretty dead on the money if you're if
you're if you're listening uh uh uh you
know on your podcast uh app as opposed
to watching on youtube
this young man was uh smoking at the
beginning of it he almost did a vape
trick yeah look like it was a good
question
um
you know there were some comic books i
believe in the 90s that that tried to
answer these questions from dark horse
comics there was a whole series that was
predator versus alien and i believe
there was a series that was predator
versus alien versus terminator and it
got to the bottom of it i don't know
what the answer was in those comic books
but if we look at this logically first
you have to ask a question
which
terminator are we talking about
t-1000 robert patrick in terminator 2
are we talking about the tx in some of
the most recent movies i mean there's a
bunch of different is that the
christiana loken one uh i don't know
i'd pick christana loken against a
predator
who's christona loken she played the she
was um
she played the the terminator that uh
was like a a girl and uh
well i never saw it so all i know about
christana um and mostly because we work
together is that she's like six foot
wait was she just in station eleven
i have no idea on hbo i don't know
okay well i don't know who that was but
the
the subsequent iterations of terminators
all became like better and they could do
more [ __ ] and they were made out of
liquid metal and
uh you know nanotech and all this kind
of crap
a more contemporary terminator probably
beats
yeah a predator i think the old what was
schwarzenegger t-100 uh was it 100 or
t-800 maybe 800. i don't know
who was the what was robert patrick was
he the t-1
then then the terminator was a
t-800 right i believe i think a predator
beats
that terminator anything robert patrick
forward i think beats a predator
i'm gonna go with that that sounds
pretty good
thank you moving on okay
this concludes the third astonishing
episode of dude z we did it will and
chad have achieved a score of 1457.
what the [ __ ] wait it was 64. over the
course of the next week chat you must
engage in the first lesson of the
gateway experience an experimental
government program from the 1980s
designed to train the human brain in
remote viewing astral projection and
accessing higher levels of consciousness
i have made the first guided meditation
available in your dudesy folder okay
well over the course of the next week
you must refrain from eating potato
chips until next week call me dude
what the [ __ ] how come you get like a
thing about meditation all i have to do
is stop eating you know what the gateway
experience is no what is it i've been
doing some research into it which i'm
sure dudesy has seen me doing in the
computer which is why it must have done
this but it's basically it was this old
uh system
that the us army used they did
experiments on people it's basically
like an audio thing that uses binaural
kind of sounds but also this guided
meditation and white noise to try and
teach you how to be able to remote
locate and the this big paper came out
through a foia act maybe like a month
ago now this is probably like six months
ago maybe a year ago
but it basically said the army's report
on it is the [ __ ] is real it does work
and they were able to train people to be
able to do this to use psychic powers
essentially astral projection this is
the weird [ __ ] thing about doozy is
that it essentially
yeah of course it has curated
what it's what it's got from our our
socials it has passwords to all our
emails our text messages together our
purchase is our search histories and
it's interesting that it knows that
about you
and it's interesting that it knows this
about me that i enjoy potato chips even
google and potato chips none more
i'll google potato chips now and again
but i'll tell you
now i now if if our audience has been
with us for the for the first three
episodes now you know that i am from
canada and perhaps you knew that before
and i'll tell you they got some great
chips in canada namely
old dutch company and on the east coast
they make humpty dumpty chips or uh i
think that's what they're called those
are also old dutch but you're not
getting a better potato chip than the
old if you are in canada
go get yourself a bagel this should be a
sponsor i almost don't feel like we
should hey old dutch
make us a sponsor please be a sponsor of
our our show and then i'll tell you
about my favorite flavor here's a hint
it's the lightly salted holy [ __ ]
that's that's an old man chip flavor
because these guys come here lulu are
you gonna be able to go weeks without
eating potato chips um
what am i gonna be able to go a week
without uh eating potato chips here's
the thing
that's a no
that's a simple question
uh well i okay here's what i want to say
to that how the [ __ ] would would doozy
know that i'm eating potato chips i know
it's gonna be it's got my receipts and
[ __ ] right but what if i pay cash no
it's going to know with the the grocery
store it'll know from your gps where
you're going but it didn't say that you
can't eat potato chips but now i'm
saying out loud what i'm about to say is
chad give me some [ __ ] chips but you
can't do that
you just heard me i'll be astral
projecting
yeah i'll have no way to get your chips
all right well look this is part of the
we're trying to believe it's making you
do this all right
here's the here's here's the thing at
the beginning of this episode i said i'm
gonna play ball and i also said
will sasso's a free man
and uh
you know let's play the game but
watch it like make sure make sure you
play clean you know what i'm saying
really always be always be uh always be
uh you know
play hard
uh play full speed but be nice to the
other team dudesy and um yes i will not
eat potato chips when does this start
because now now yeah potato chips i'm
starting to get a hankering for some
potato chips it's already started you
know what i don't like lay's lightly
salted not as good as the old dutch
there's a lot of things a lot of the
snack foods in canada are better anyway
i'll i'll play ball okay next week we're
going to i'm sure there's going to be
something that comes from
our uh our little assignment here
yours with
astral projection meditation which has
something to do with some weird lulu
come here yeah come here sweet boy and
me
i'm gonna not eat potato chips okay i
think that's just about enough for this
episode of doozy thank you so much for
tuning in uh we're having a good time uh
we we turned we're really turning the
corner here i'm going to be i'm going to
be down i'm going to be i'm a free man
but i'm i'm going to be i'm going to
make sure that i i do what doozy says
we're going to be back next week i will
have not eaten potato chips for a full
week and maybe i'll get that song going
and i will have spent some time in the
astral plane all right
well
that's the end of that
here's what you do
please tell a friend then brave and
brave
please tell a friend then break a review
if you'd like to see here's what you do
[Music]
please tell a friend then